Special envoy Kerry, the cyclone we're seeing
in India is really hitting home the message
that more of those storms in the future are
a global threat.
At the same time, the US is proud of having
gathered fifty five percent of global GDP
at that virtual summit.
Yet Germany insists on exceptions.
It doesn't want to leave coal till 2038.
The US is continuing fracking.
So how do you want to convince poorer countries
to do their part in the climate effort?
Well, it's critical that the 20 biggest emitters
in the world of which we are one and the EU
counts as a whole as one, and India and China
and others, we have to step up.
All of us have to lead here by example.
And that means we need to be achieving significant
reduction goals, not just by 2050, but over
the next 10 years.
If we 20 nations that are the largest economies
of the world don't mitigate- meaning, reduce
our emissions during 2020 to 2030- then we
would be responsible for denying the rest
of the world the ability to hold the temperature
well below two degrees or at one point five.
So that's our imperative.
That's what we're trying to do now, hopefully
achieve through climate diplomacy over the
course of the next months before we go to
Glasgow.
So in Glasgow, the less developed world will
be able to know that we've got the hundred
billion dollars we pulled together that has
been promised and that we are doing our part
to keep one point five degrees alive.
Now, reducing emissions is the one thing - at
the same time, the Earth's lung's under threat.
Brazilian President Bolsonaro was also around
that table pledging that he would reduce illegal
logging, stop it till 2030.
At the same time, the Amazon rainforest is
seeing a 10-year high in its decrease.
How is the United States going to apply pressure
that those pledges are also met?
Well, we're working with President Bolsonaro
and with his team.
We've had several conversations.
We were certainly encouraged that he talked
about stopping the deforestation.
But we believe, obviously, as do many scientists
and others in the world who are experts on
the Amazon, that we can't wait till 2030.
We have to move much sooner than that.
But we have to work with the country, the
sovereign nation that has control over its
own land and reach some kind of an agreement
if we possibly can.
Obviously, there will be a need to have some
kind of enforcement that's credible and that
we have a different approach to this than
we've had previously.
There's no guarantee we can get there, but
we're certainly going to try together with
other nations that are deeply concerned about
this.
Now, you've just met all major political actors
ahead of the September elections, the end
of the Merkel era here in Germany.
How would you feel about the government going
green?
Looking at the polling, the Greens could actually
have for the first time the chance to form
a government here.
How would you feel about a Green government
at the helm of Europe's largest economy going
into that crucial climate summit in November?
Well, it's up to the people of Germany to
decide, you know, it's not up to me and how
I feel or President Biden feels about it.
We certainly support the policy of addressing
climate crisis.
And obviously the Greens are very seized by
and engaged in that particular issue.
But this is for the campaign ahead, not for
us.
And unlike Russia, we're not going to involve
ourselves in other people's elections.
But you also discussed with the Pope that
he should probably participate in that climate
summit.
Is that a sign that you politicians will no
longer be able to solve it alone?
No.
It's a sign that a head of state member, he's
also a head of state,
...not a very big one though, but...
Not a very big one.
But it speaks volumes that even as a small
one, that is a very, very powerful moral leader
in the world and the leader of more than just
the one point one billion Catholics, but a
very powerful voice who wrote a remarkable
document, Laudato si.
I think he can help invigorate the folks who
are gathered there and have a message for
the world about the importance of what is
happening there.
But there'll be many leaders there who will
also join in that effort.
This is the world's most important moment
with respect to multilateralism and a global
effort to solve a major international challenge.
And if we don't get it right in Glasgow, then
we will be leaving certain parts of the world
in chaos and disorder and a great pain over
years, over the ensuing years, the less developed
world has not caused this problem, and they
are patiently waiting for the developed world
to step up and exercise their responsibility.
And young people are asking adults to behave
like adults and get the job done.
So that's what's at stake.
And I think having...
I'm delighted to hear that His Holiness wants
to come and wants to do this, and I think
his voice will be very important.
Now, you yourself have cited nine years left
to go to avoid no longer being able to meet
the one point five degree aim.
At the same time, you want to rely on largely
uninvented technology.
Are you simply being optimistic?
Well, let me answer two parts of that.
First of all, it's a mistake just to kind
of have a finite number of nine years, etc.
Scientists gave us a broad range saying about
12 years left to make the most important decisions
to avoid the worst consequences of climate.
But nobody can be that precise with respect
the environment about one year or two years.
The idea is we have a very short period of
time and we have to ...we have to make those
decisions.
Now, what I said about invention with respect
to it, the IEA, the International Energy Agency,
has said that forty two to forty six critical
technologies are not yet capable of being
brought to scale and put into the marketplace.
That's what I was saying.
It's not that we haven't invented some of
these things.
It is that they're not at a scale where they
are commercially viable yet.
And what we need to do is get green hydrogen
or battery storage or storage of some kind
and other things, able to be able to be brought
to the marketplace at scale.
That's when it becomes a really viable opportunity.
But certainly with solar and with wind and
hydro and geothermal, we have a set of options
that get us very, very close in many, many
places where those are available.
And we can do... a lot of nations are already
coming extremely close just with renewable
to being able to provide energy security.
I'm confident we can do this if we put our
mind to it.
And very large sums of money are now beginning
to move from the private sector into investment
in the sustainable alternative renewable development
field.
So I think, you know, I'm confident and optimistic
about our ability to get this done, providing
we pay close attention not just to 30 years
from now with a big target, but with a very
specific set of plans for how we will reduce
sufficiently over the next 10 years, 2020
to 2030 is the key decade of decision.
And that's what we'll decide a significant
part of all of our future of the planet's
future.
Just one final question.
When such close allies get together, surely
you have to talk about the situation in the
Middle East right now.
How much longer will the United States block
a resolution calling for an end to the fighting
in the United Nations?
Look, I'm not ducking your question, but it's
not my daily work right now.
I'm the climate envoy and President Biden
and Secretary Blinken are speaking to this
issue, and I'll leave it to them to do so.
Special Envoy for Climate John Kerry, thank
you very much for talking to Deutsche Welle.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.